a six-point lead once again for
Sacramento a team that set such a bright
future and I like the additions they
made after the crossover create space
and almost take it away
Newland all the way to the cops know
Malik Newman he started at Mississippi
State Malik Newman trying to make it
happen gets to the rim Leighton can last
year for the charge tried it Villanova
can start with it down by nine Malik
Newman a good looking he takes advantage
of it
watch his feet side just PO goes right
into his jump shot away by new buddy
don't go Seinfeld bumpers Eric mica
played Germany last year Malik Newman
bought the takeaway an all over a lot of
mo the Cavaliers at UNK earlier this
week and we're still watching it was the
fun it was the photo of the certificate
no question
buthe team that will develop especially
with that young pool playmaking is
certainly picked up for Sacramento think
that 17 assists now and in the second
and 24 Ford's up to 16 Sacramento Newman
on the fall away
and at one point r- on the tie game at
89 mid-range you love this don't say I
like hot inside of 10 they took their
time on this possession what's up you
guys this Taylor Brooks with bleach
report make sure that you subscribe for
some more video content